de l'eau devenue le cauchemar du musée
girodet à montargis depuis qu'elle s'est
engouffré par cette grille dans les
réserves où étaient stockés près de
trois mille oeuvres qu'il faut remonter
une à une pour constater les dégâts
celle-ci est peut-être perdu là elle a
passé deux jours dans l'eau donc il va
falloir faire un premier état des lieux
pour savoir ce qu'il en est et qu'elles
sont et et les conséquences de cette
immersion dans une des salles du musée
c'est désormais une exposition d'oeuvres
du 19e siècle déformé par l'eau et
salies par la boue qu'il faut patiemment
restauré avec une infinie précaution
gamme itil et une restauratrice
indépendante
mais face au désastre avec d'autres elle
est venue bénévolement
on élimine la boue qui a été déposée
avec l'eau afin d'éviter que la vie ne
sèche avec cette pellicule en surface
que celle ci ne viennent donc
s'incruster dans l'oeuvre est aussi
qu'elle ne soit une source de nutriments
90 cros organismes c'est ce qu'on veut
surtout éviter les oeuvres doivent
ensuite séché mais il faudra surveiller
de près l'arrivée éventuelle de
champigny